The distance between points 'A' and 'B' is 8 kilometers.
Zen begins at point 'A' and covers half this distance at 2 kilometers per hour.
Half the distance would be 4 kilometers.
and from this point to B,
he travels at 4 kilometers per hour.
As the total distance is 8 kilometers,
and this is 4 kilometers, this distance will equal 4 kilometers.
So he runs half the distance at 2 kilometers per hour.
And the remaining half at 4 kilometers per hour.
What will be his average speed?
Yes, we haven't seen this concept of average speed earlier!
Pause the video and try to find this average speed.
It's easy.
As he travels half the distance at 2 kilometres per hour,
and the remaining half at 4 kilometres per hour,
his average speed will be 2 plus 4 over 2.
This is the average of the two numbers.
That will be 6 over 2 or 3 kilometres per hour.
That's Zen's average speed over this distance.
And as some of you might have guessed.
This is a classic mistake that many students make.
So what is the average speed?
There is just one thing we need to understand about average speed.
It equals the ratio of the total distance travelled
to the total time taken to travel that distance.
Yes, total distance divided by the total time.
So let's see what it will be in this case.
The total distance travelled is '4 plus 4' or '8 kilometers'.
And what is the total time taken?
We haven't been given the total time taken.
But can we find that out?
The time taken is equal to the distance divided by the speed.
And the total time taken will equal the sum of the
times taken to travel each part.
The time taken to travel the initial '4 kilometres' will equal '4 over 2'.
And the time taken to travel the second part will equal 4 over 4.
The sum equals the total time taken by Zen
to cover the distance between points 'A' and 'B'.
The numerator will equal 8.
And the denominator will equal 'two plus 1'.
Zen takes 3 hours to travel from point 'A to point B'.
We get the average speed as '8 over 3'.
That's approximately 2.66 km per hour.
Wait a moment.
Look at the two speeds Zen travelled at.
Two and four kilometres per hour.
Why is the average speed closer to two?
Why isn't it closer to four?
Here's the answer! The average speed is closer to two kilometres per hour
because Zen is travelling for more time at that speed.
He is travelling at two kilometres per hour for two hours.
And at four kilometres per hour for one hour.
If Zen would have travelled for more time
at four kilometres per hour,
the average speed would have been closer to four kilometres per hour
and not two kilometers per hour.
Now let's look at a new example on a new page.
Zen travels at two kilometers per hour for half hour.
And then at four kilometers per hour for two hours.
What will be his average speed?
Pause the video and give it a shot.
We just learnt that the average speed equals the total distance
divided by the total time taken to travel that distance.
Do we have the total distance? No, but we can find that out.
Yes, it will be the sum of these two distances.
The product of speed and time gives us the distance.
Two multiplied by one half will give us this distance.
And four times two will give us this distance.
This sum gives us the total distance.
And the total time will equal the sum of these two time duration's.
One half plus two.
This is one plus eight which is nine.
And the denominator will be 0.5 plus 2 which is 2.5.
Let's zoom out and write the answer.
We get 9 over 2.5.
To solve this we can multiply the numerator and the denominator by 4.
We get 36 over 10 which equals 3.6  kilometres per hour.
This as we can see is closer to four kilometres per hour.
It's closer to 4 kilometers per hour
because he's travelling for more time at that speed.
Let's look at one last problem to understand average speed.
Zen travels at 3 kilometers per hour for 6 kilometers.
And 5 kilometers per hour for 10 kilometers.
What will be his average speed?
Pause the video and solve this one.
The average speed is the ratio of the total distance,
to the total time taken to travel that distance.
The total distance will be 6 plus 10.
What will be the total time?
It will be the sum of the time duration's for each of these parts.
The time taken to cover this part will equal 6 over 3 or 2 hours.
And the time taken to travel this part will equal '10 over 5' or 2 hours.
So the total time will equal 2 plus 2 or 4 hours.
That will equal 16 over 4.
4 kilometres per hour.
Is this closer to 3 or to 5?
It's equidistant from each.
And why is that?
It's because he is traveling for the same time at each of the speeds.
Hence this is the average of the individual speed rates.
We will look at more examples of average speed
over the next few sessions.